[Music]
our me artis and welcome back to game
sports coverage 338 this is a beard
my name is Oscar nails I'm joined by
Dave joy hello how are you Dave I'm very
well we very well I've just been to
check out skull and bones which I know
you've played as well great
is it a budget assassin's creed 4
because that's what we all thought when
we saw it revealed right no no
absolutely not that's what I thought for
me it's taken like the best parts of
like the ship combat from Assassin's
Creed Black Flag that like the piece of
the game that took everyone by surprise
and everyone spent like way more time in
it and they thought they would it's
taken that as like the bare bare bones
and expanded on it's of a huge agree
like the world the combat have things
control the variety of ships the
atmosphere it's it's it's just like that
whole gameplay segment from Black Flag
was near blueprints and outs just
explode out control and I bloody love it
is from what I've seen the combat seems
a lot more deep than what we saw invite
back is that is that fair comment when
you say yeah definitely and there's
things like
if your ship you're aiming your front
cannons the house
stern whatever diet drink that's all of
it you fly a chain shop which can you
know disable masts if you win your
broadsiding you can you can do critical
hits when you're hitting like things
like this dock the waterline ships have
their own unique abilities like one of
the ships because can use a battering
ram on ships so yeah I use that one that
one is really fun like charging at the
phone it reminds me of like we'd be you
know the bayonetta in called you a world
war ii then else did I say bayonet yeah
that's about Libya you said Bayonetta
alright yeah babe it's been a long week
the mobile to charging or someone except
is with a ship right yeah it's got like
a risk/reward to oh yeah and if you if
you land it if you like massive damage
but then some ships are nice and
maneuverable and they can they can do
certain things so like cancer that like
depending on where your sails are you
can cut the wind or the wind
- come side on alright your bear you can
do things like trimming yourselves to go
faster or weighing anchor so you can
like Tokyo Drift your way around to get
like a quick broadside and then gather
some furious pirate edition watch that
yet to me like that when I first started
playing it I was like this seems way too
complex and like the HUD is like all
over the place and like there's wind
profiles of each ship and and different
repair mechanics and bracing and
different guns that you have and I was
like oh this is a bit much for the end
of e3 week but actually when you realize
what's going on you know you notice that
that's actually just a very deep combat
system right and the moment-to-moment
gameplay is incredibly complex but
hopefully that will give it the
longevity that I feel like this needs
because at the moment we don't really
know enough
I don't think about the meta game like I
enjoyed the moment-to-moment stuff but I
don't really know what the sort of
overarching goal is I think it's the
same with a lot of Ubisoft multiplayer
games if you take Rainbow six and for
honor for example is they're both very
satisfying to play at an entry level
like a satisfying to get kills it's
satisfying to clash swords and it's
satisfying to fire cannons in the ship
but there's this huge depth in for honor
there's huge depth in Rainbow six siege
and there's gonna from what I've seen so
far there's gonna be a lot of depth to
just common bones as well I think that's
what Ubisoft Studios do really well they
their gameplay allows for like a
spectrum of abilities and skill ceilings
yeah and I really liked the disguise
mechanic as well you can with a slight
teaming up yeah there was a great moment
in the in the demo where I salvaged the
Portuguese sails to disguise my ship as
a Portuguese merchants and in the
gameplay trailer the ship does that just
sneak past for all I did is I disguise
myself and I I I kind of just hated
myself because because there's other
pirates in the world and in the demo
there was like seven other people and
slowly but surely in that this other
player had said like player eight but
her head was was closing the gap to me
and they just thought I was AI and all
of a sudden it was like about turn full
broadside rocket barrage ramming speed
and the guy in the demo booth next to me
screamed because it's just like a
surprise attack out of
we're and it's like if it's like that
silly thing you can do and it's it's
it's just that again it's a another
layer of depth and that was one demo I'm
looking forward to seeing what other
weird and wonderful stuff we can do like
when people team up when you get clans
together and your ships together when
you can betray people I'm super excited
for this game yeah I'm really excited to
see more but for everything else on
skullenbones and for everything else
from e3 2018 stay tuned to GameXplain
[Music]
[Music]